oh hey wow
thanks for joining me i'm starting to
get pretty lonely in here
i just wanted to talk about my favorite
anime attack on titan
it's a brutal story about the last of
humanity living behind massive walls
that protect their civilization because
on the other side are horrifying giant
monsters called titans whose only desire
in life is to eat people alive
they're also incredibly weird in fact
they tend to be straight up comically
bizarre
these big-eyed creatures are not the
classic monsters you might be used to
seeing though it's exactly their uncanny
nature that
makes these titans so effectively
terrifying but in today's video i wanted
to give you a taste of what it would
really look like if titans were real
i'll do my best to avoid story spoilers
and we'll only be pulling from the anime
shown so far
as opposed to the manga source material
so you won't be sending any fish bones
here
the titans range from 3 meters tall to
15 meters tall
and usually generally humanoid in shape
the proportions can be kind of crazy i
mean just take a look at this gluttonous
dude right here
look at him oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no
but a cool twist to this type of story
comes from the addition of what are
called titan shifters
they're people who can turn into massive
specialized titans at will
and these titans oh man they are awesome
they're basically giant mech suits the
same that you'd see in pacific rim or
gundam wing or even
power rangers but these guys are fleshy
they even have their own little fleshy
pilot cabins
it's the idea of a mech suit as a
superpower and when they fight they tend
to reduce their surroundings to rubble
so they're obviously really big by the
nature of them being animated
it's kind of hard to discern their true
scale how big are these titans really
well the show often reminds us exactly
what the scale of the world is
it's got to be 14 meters seven meter
titan 17 meters tall
two 15 meter titans four meter companion
sony
we know that the main character aaron
yeager has a titan form that is 15
meters tall
and if he existed in real life this is
what he would look like
towering over these industrial buildings
of los angeles
another titan shifter is aaron's biggest
rival the armored titan
although much wider and more built he's
the same height as the attack titan and
the rivalry between these two is pretty
awesome
you wouldn't want to be anywhere nearby
when they start fighting
the creator of attack on titan hajime
isa yama is said to have designed
aaron's titan
after the professional fighter yushin
okamai and i definitely see the
resemblance
the attack titan is basically just a
bigger version of him
and that got me wondering how big humans
can actually be
for some context okama and i are both
about six foot two
even though the average male height is
about five foot nine levi ackerman on
the other hand
is five foot three yet despite his short
stature he's easily the coolest
character in the entire show
but to be considered an actual real live
giant
you have to be at least seven feet tall
like the most famous example
the kazam legend shaquili o'nealy
it is absurdly rare to be as tall as him
in fact you are five times more likely
to be struck by lightning
than to be as tall as shaq but there's
only one person who can hold the record
for the tallest person
of all time and that was robert madlow
standing at almost
nine feet tall his height made him
famous and even toured with the ringling
brothers circus
perhaps unsurprisingly though he also
holds the record for the largest hands
and
feets of any person in recorded history
sadly though his size caused multiple
health complications and he ended up
dying at the age of 22.
the human body struggles to work
correctly when it's this big
but why is this
it's incredibly easy to imagine a giant
you just think of a person but
bigger the problem is that when you
scale something up the physics don't
scale up
the same way for example strength is
determined by the cross-sectional area
of something the more cross-sectional
area you have the more strength you have
it's why bones are easier to break this
way than that way however the mass of an
object is determined by its volume
as an object gets bigger it gets heavier
faster
then it gets stronger the strength
increases by the square
but the mass increases by the cube and
the difference between these two numbers
increases exponentially in physics this
is what is called the square
cubed law as things get bigger strength
just can't keep up with the weight gain
so you have to compensate
this is the exact reason why elephants
have such thick legs to hold up their
heavy bodies
and it's also the exact reason why the
largest animal in the world the blue
whale
can only exist with the buoyant force of
water holding it up
attack on titan explains all this away
by simply saying the titans weigh a lot
less than they
should it actually kind of makes sense
if you want your titans to realistically
hold their shape
and considering how fictional the show
is it's an appreciated effort
now there's one more titan that i
haven't talked about yet the largest one
the colossal titan
[Music]
he debuts in the first episode by
smashing a hole in the outer wall
literally kick-starting the story as a
flood of mindless titans enter the city
the colossal titan is truly gargantuan
it's portrayed as a living skyscraper
towering over everything as it lays
waste to it all
so how big is the colossal titan he's
listed at being 60 meters tall
that's huge however when we start
thinking in relative terms
he becomes a little less imposing for
example
this is a football field and this is the
colossal titan
at less than 200 feet tall he wouldn't
even come close to the full height of
the statue of
liberty which most new yorkers will tell
you isn't really all that big
for them it's just that little thing off
in the distance you know now here's
something that blew my mind
remember that little boat that got stuck
well the colossal titan could lay down
on that ship
sideways like i'm talking without
sticking out on either side or hanging
off at all
this really makes the titan look tiny
although to be honest i think this is
more just a testament to how huge these
ships are than anything else i mean this
ship is larger than the empire state
building
and if you want to find out how it got
stuck i recommend checking out practical
engineering
if you've seen godzilla vs king kong
you're already familiar with the two
most famous titans that humanity has
come up with with
kong over 100 meters tall and godzilla
at 120 meters
godzilla is literally twice as tall as
the colossal titan and
i don't know how to feel about that they
would probably just kind of ignore him
as a nuisance
so then why does the colossal titan
appear so
colossal we touched on this in an
episode of animators react
for one the show can get away with
things you can't in real life because
it's a cartoon
you can exaggerate different scales by
simply having different field of views
for the foreground versus
the background also intentionally making
something appear larger builds a sense
of tension and visual drama when you
have to face an unfathomably large
opponent
they take this even further by making
the attack titan appear tiny when he's
trying to fight back like he literally
looks like this tall
like seriously look at him he's barely
as tall as the first floor of the
building how is any of this to scale
a more common example of this idea is
the wall surrounding humanity it's a 50
meter wall which is
certainly a huge wall as far as walls go
however the way it's depicted in the
show makes it appear like it's the wall
from game of thrones
and you'd totally be forgiven for
thinking they're the same size
however the wall from game of thrones is
over four times larger
than the wall from attack on titan
that's well over three times taller than
the colossal titan he would not be able
to scale that wall
although it is the colossal titan he's a
very hot dude
maybe he could just lean up against the
wall and just melt through it i don't
know what i'm saying here listen we've
all seen airplanes before you know the
boeing 747 imagine leaning that
against the wall of attack on titan but
now notice how the houses are way
smaller than the plane see this is what
i'm talking about they say the wall is
50 meters tall but then they visualize
it being like
200 meters tall but you know what i get
it no one
actually cares about the discrepancy and
size consistency across multiple levels
it's about the emotional impact of the
imagery when it comes to anime i would
take that any day for the sake of being
cooler and more impactful
part of why i love attack on titan so
much is that regardless of how dark the
story can get
it's about perseverance it's about not
giving up in the face of adversity
no matter what happens keep moving
[Music]
forward
ah thank you so much for watching this
video i really appreciate you tuning in
this one had a lot of cgi in it so i
wanted to give our friends at puget
systems a shout out because
even though we're crunched on time we're
able to still make stupid stuff like
that
i mean there's no reason for this shot
to exist and yet there it is
and to be completely honest like our
whole studios outfitted with puget
systems at this point they make our
lives so easy
like you don't have to know how to build
a computer at all and if you do they
save you so much time by testing it they
figure out the best computer to fit your
needs
for instance we've got several computers
with 30 90s in them now and we even got
amd ryzen processors we've got 64 cores
ripping all kinds of threads around here
so thank you again to puget systems for
making that happen and thanks to you
for watching this video if you want to
share this video that would be the best
way
to help us and in the meantime try to
think about what i should do next time
i'm curious to see what you think thank
you for watching i'll see in the next
one